even as all eyes are focused on the case
of george floyd and police misconduct in
minneapolis
there's another troubling issue that's
getting some well deserved attention
all the way to the white house a spike
in violent attacks against
asian americans across the country
an uptick in recent weeks in violent
attacks
against asian americans this
surveillance video capturing an alleged
assailant
in california violently shoving an 84
year old thai
american man to the ground he died of
his injuries days later
this surveillance footage shows a 71
year old asian grandmother violently
shoved to the ground
her purse stolen 52 year old woman
being pushed to the ground on roosevelt
avenue in flushing queens tuesday
a 91 year old man pushed in oakland's
chinatown
the 36 year old victim who is
asian-american walking when his attacker
runs up behind
and stabs him vicious hate crimes
against asian-americans
who've been attacked harassed blamed and
scapegoated
at this very moment so many of them
are fellow americans they're on the
front lines of this pandemic trying to
save lives
and still still they're forced to live
in fear
for their lives just walking down
streets in america
it's wrong it's un-american and it
must stop
we're joined now by john yang of the
group asian americans advancing justice
and mr yang thank you for being here
tonight
were you heartened to see president
biden address this issue
absolutely oftentimes asian americans
struggle for visibility
we are are thinking ourselves does
anyone see us especially
during this time when we've seen these
heightened attacks against our community
to have the president speak out so
forcefully and denounce these attacks
against our community
gives us hope there's still a long road
ahead but at least we know that
someone sees us during this time
and what do you think is at the heart of
this mr young
unfortunately there's a lot of things
going on and to be clear
we've seen this since back in january of
2020 when covet 19
first hit our shores in the united
states because of misinformation
disinformation
people have this association that
somehow asian americans are diseased or
special carriers of covet 19
and unfortunately we've seen that before
in history where we've had the so-called
yellow peril back in the late 1800s
or other issues where asian americans
are seen as the perpetual foreigner
so certainly number one that is a driver
as to
why there is this fear why there are
these attacks but the other thing we
need to remember is that
we are seeing a lot of economic
insecurity we
are seeing a lot of fear and whenever
people have fear
they look for someone to blame and
unfortunately in this case
the asian american community has become
a target
a question for you mr yang from rhonda
schwartz rhonda
john what if do you have any advice
if you are attacked or if perhaps you
see an attack like this going on what
should people do
sure and there's a lot of good things
that people can do and i appreciate that
question
first is it's important to report it
it's certainly
again it goes to this notion of
visibility that we've talked to
so our organization has a website called
stand against hatred dot org
where people can report heat incidents
so that we can document it we can tell
stories around it
the second thing i would encourage
people to consider is get what is called
bystander intervention training
so that allows a person if they see an
act of hate
and it doesn't have to be directed at
the asian american community but if they
see an act of hate or racism
they can do something about it now to be
clear i'm not asking people to be
superheroes and jump
in and stop something but there's
oftentimes little things that you can do
that makes that victim just feel a
little bit better and suffer a little
bit
less trauma in that moment
let me ask you this uh the role of
former president trump he continues to
refer to
kova 19 as the chinese virus he hasn't
been helpful has he
unfortunately he has absolutely not been
helpful and even just a few days ago
before president biden spoke
he referred to it again as the china
virus and certainly we know that anytime
language that is used like that it has
caused a spike in anti-asian racism
so it is clear that that is one of the
causes
clauses
the fact is that these words matter they
matter to making people
think about cloven 19 in a certain way
to cause people to blame a certain
community for clove at 19.
and that i think president biden had it
right that has to stop
that's un-american
and do you see it stopping since his
speech last week
well unfortunately it's going to be a
long journey and number one is
we hope that as people become more aware
of this issue
people start to respond to it react to
it in a good way
but i think the other thing we have to
recognize is that this isn't going to go
away
anytime soon you know the reality is we
do have
geopolitical tensions with the chinese
government and those are real and those
are justifiable
but anytime you have these types of
world tensions there's
a need or a desire to blame a particular
community
and so even after covet 19 passes or is
under control
this is still an issue this issue of
racism that we all
must work on together
all right john yang of the group asian
americans advancing justice
thank you so much for being here tonight
thank you very much
coming up next this week's winners and
losers in the media
see if you agree with the choices made
by the editors of mediaite
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law on crime trial network